Russia's revenge on cities across
Ukraine in response to Saturday's strike
on the Kirch Bridge connecting Russia
with Crimea President Putin's Pet
Project symbol of his illegal claim to
Crimea a terrorist attack by Ukrainian
Special Forces he says now
operations is
TV the long list of cities struck and
the devastating aftermath no mention
here of Civilian casualties despite the
fact these are clearly not all military
targets
horrific as these stripes are spreading
fear and Terror in cities across Ukraine
they may not make a material difference
on the battlefield and although to a
certain extent they have appeased the
pro-war camp who President Putin was
obviously worried about those same
voices are still clamoring for more
sustained action
[Music]
leader ramzan kadiroff who has promised
to send another 70 000 of his men to
fight a terrifying Prospect if these
fresh pictures are anything to go by
said now he was 100 satisfied and that
Russia hadn't even started yet
well-known War journalists saying this
shouldn't be a one-off Act
on moscow's ukrainski or Ukrainian
Boulevard we speak to some who are
devastated by the latest attacks I find
this morning strike extremely disturbing
because it there is no purpose
strategically or intellectual and
I see no point of those strikes
I think this is very sad and peaceful
people don't deserve to suffer
but then there are so many others who'll
accept just about anything their
president does are you sure that this is
the Putin Cent yes this morning yes
you're sure yeah he just he just who
Putin did he just gave a security
council meeting and he said that this
was his response to the kirchbridge
attack
this is what's his response to the
bridge attack yes okay uh
this is uh the right response the signs
of opposition no to war are there if you
look hard enough but they don't stand a
chance not against a president hell bent
on Victory whatever the human cost
dynamagne Sky News Moscow